yep the rumors are true this is my
husband Gary
just got married married that's right
Denise Richards and Aaron fibers are
officially husband and wife I've been so
blessed a source tells ET that the duo
said I do in an intimate ceremony in
Malibu California late Saturday
afternoon
just days after news broke of their
engagement according to the source
Denise and Aaron's nuptials were filmed
for the upcoming season of The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills it was
announced early last month that the 47
year old actress would be joining the
cast of the Bravo reality show are you
excited I am excited I thought you know
what it's I'm a fan of the show and I
never I don't know I never saw myself
fancy enough to ever you know feed one
of the housewives but it's uh I thought
why not but back to the wedding the
bride looked stunning in a high-low
white wedding dress by designer mark
Zunino which featured a lace strapless
romper with a tulle skirt Denise
completed her look with her blonde locks
curled and parted to the side
Cimino instagrammed this photo with the
woman of the hour along with this
shocking caption quote 24 hours to make
a wedding dress no problem as for the
guest list
Denise's new Real Housewives co-stars
the Lisa Vanderpump and her husband Ken
Todd were in attendance
so we're camille Grammer and her fiance
David Meyer Rebecca Romijn and Jerry
O'Connell were also amongst the
attendees and despite reports that
Richards ex-husband Charlie Sheen was at
the wedding
the actors rep Jeff Ballard exclusively
tells et that Sheen did not attend but
quote wishes them both nothing but
happiness just because we're not married
I still always felt we were still a
family and Charlie does too
this marks the second marriage for
Richards she and Sheen were married from
2002 to 2006 and share two daughters
fourteen-year-old Sam and 13-year old
Lola the actress also has a 7 year old
adopted daughter named Eloise
meanwhile Piper's finalized his divorce
from Nicollette Sheridan last month the
pair had been separated for two years
after being married for six diapers and
Richard started dating less than a year
ago et has reached out to Richards rep
for comment
[Music]